This is actually a very good question.
So let's start from the basics.
Research universities or simply universities
versus the university of Applied Sciences,
also known as Hawk School.
Okay, these both are the higher
educational institutions in the Netherlands
and you can get both bachelor's and masters in there.
Research university is a bit more theoretical
and it's considered a higher level of education
compared to the university of Applied Sciences,
which is a bit more practical
but considered a bit on the lower level kind of.
In university
you only study for three years,
whereas in Hawk School
you study for 4 years during your bachelor's.
Hawk schools are also a bit cheaper,
but it really depends on what you want to study.
If you want to study arts,
then you should definitely go to Hawk school.
But if you want to study management or philosophy,
then it is university.
And let me know if you have any more questions.